bakou
8 heures c'est le début d'une journée
ordinaire pour la sicile 280 migrants
débarqués au port de messine à bord de
ce bateau affrété par l'agencé
européenne frontex des syriens les
soudanais des erythréens ils ont été
sauvés après 12 jours d'errance en
méditerranée leur traversée a débuté sur
les côtes égyptiennes en moyenne elle a
coûté 2000 euros par personne avant
d'arriver en italie à mère professeur de
philosophie a fui damas en syrie avec sa
femme et ses deux enfants de 7 et 10 ans
leur premier objectif se laver après des
semaines de voyage on va manger et se
reposer pendant un ou deux jours aurait
pu ensuite on va continuer notre chemin
car pour un maire la sicile n'est qu'une
étape dans cette longue transhumance sa
destination malmö en suède
sur les 90 mille réfugiés qui accostent
en sicile 85% reparti immédiatement pour
continuer leur voyage plus au nord avant
d'obtenir des papiers ces migrants
patientent souvent des mois dans des
centres d'accueil
mineo le plus grand centre d'hébergement
d'europe est une ancienne base de l'otan
il prend en charge plus de 3000
personnes sur les douze mille réfugiés
restent est actuellement en sicile
devant le centre
nous avons rencontré un jeune malien de
26 ans il a préféré rester anonyme pour
les recours permet les heureux comme
beaucoup de migrants sa demande de
récépissé est refusé pour l'union
européenne
le mali est un pays sûr il risque
l'expulsion ne sait encore plusieurs
années mais après je voulais retourner
là bas comme ça parce que - comme les
mineurs eux sont mieux prises en charge
la loi italienne impose un tuteur chargé
de les accompagner dans leurs démarches
camara modibo 17 ans vient d'effectuer
seul un dangereux périple depuis la
gambie ils m'ont attrapée et nous
fracasser les doigts c'est cette
histoire là qu'il va falloir raconté à
la commission
carla trop milo est avocate à syracuse
et oriente les jeunes migros le nombre
d'éloignements ou plutôt de jeunes qui
disparaissent dans la nature car il
s'agit bien de ça c'est drastiquement
écroulé depuis qu'on mène notre activité
à floridien près de syracuse
le maire de centre gauche a dû lutter
contre ses administrés pour héberger sur
sa commune un centre d'accueil
il faut des politiques de gestion
intelligente et ça ne peut pas être
seulement à l'italie de gérer ce
phénomène mais l'île reste la première
région d'accueil d'italie ce qui crée
des tensions
ces migrants sont vus comme des rivaux
car la population pense que l'état
s'occupe d'eux et ne fait rien pour les
italiens même si en fait ce n'est pas
vrai et qu'il s'agit de budgets
différents démunis ces migrants sont
aujourd'hui une proie facile beaucoup
exploité de misère on va essayé
d'interroger des travailleurs agricoles
il devrait être en pause déjeuner excuse
moi on voulait te demander bon celui-là
déjà une fine ce sont des demandeurs
d'asile hébergés dans notre pays en fait
ils sont obligés de travailler dans des
conditions quasi d'esclavagé une main
d'oeuvre à bas coût
une aubaine pour les propriétaires
terriens
quand je vais au travail certains me
paye mais d'autres noms alors que tu
travailles il te paye 20 euros pour 12
heures voire 14 ou même 18 heures tout
ça parce qu'on n'a pas encore tous nos
papiers des papiers ultime graal après
des mois voire des années de voyage à la
merci des tortionnaires des passeurs
plus d'exploitants sans scrupules
en 2015 les nations unies tablent sur
près de 700000 arrivée sur le territoire
européen
un chiffre qui ne fera qu augmenter dans
les années à venir